[Applause]
he is the lame duck
today succumbing to tradition to spare
an errant looking far bird free
unlike most of its friends thanksgiving
is a special day for turkeys i guess
probably for the most part not a very
good one when you think about it
the jokes just about landed but one
catch phrase felt a little
flat like many turkeys at this time
mr trump perhaps knows he doesn't have
long left
keep america great and as i say america
first
shouldn't go away from that america
first
the words may survive the man must soon
retire
a fake
bring them out look at that beautiful
beautiful bird
oh so lucky that is a lucky bird this
a possible preview of some human pardons
porn i hereby grant you a full
pardon a show of mercy
the day after he got as close as he'll
ever get to a concession
a pardon for yourself the president will
now at least let the government
work with biden's transition team a man
who's trying to kick-start
a reset america is back
ready to lead the world not retreat from
it
and this is the team he wants to do it a
son of jewish cuban refugees
at the helm of homeland security my
father and mother brought me to this
country
to escape communism
multilateralism is back diplomacy
is back the first female director
of national intelligence you value the
perspective of the intelligence
community
and a well-known face president joe
biden
will trust in god and he will
also trust in science to guide our work
on earth there are no fireworks no
real surprises in these pics yes there
are a few firsts but there is also a lot
of the familiar many of these people
worked for barack obama and know joe
biden
well he did promise stability
his supporters will also demand radical
change cordelia lynch sky news
washington